pied pour le goût merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
dans un rapport paru la semaine dernière
la cour des comptes s'inquiète de la
baisse des dotations de l'état aux
collectivités locales tout le monde sait
ici c'est environ 11 milliards d'euros
sur la période 2015 2017 avec le risque
évident d'un recul inquiétant l'épargné
brute des collectivités locales d'ici à
2019 les communes vers et leur capacité
de désendettement grimper à 12 ans alors
qu'elle était actuellement en 2014
jusqu'à 8 ans les élus préparent leur
budget sans visibilité et d'état crainte
que les deux tiers des collectivités se
trouve dès 2017
face au mur dans ce contexte particulier
à la veille de la création de la
métropole aix marseille provence
nous redoutons une mise en route
fonctionnel délicate voire paralysé dès
le début de l'année aucun financement
n'étant prévue à ce jour
pour son fonctionnement vous avez
répondu très récemment un courrier que
je vous avais adressé cet été que des
amendements seraient prévues au projet
de loi de finances pouvez vous monsieur
le premier ministre nous rassurer sur
les points suivants fondamentaux pour la
création de notre peintre au paul
pouvez-vous nous assurer que la
métropole sera bien bénéficiaire du
fonds de péréquation
ceci pour garantir l'équilibré financier
du territoire métropolitain ainsi que de
marseille sa vie de centre pouvez vous
aussi vous engager à faire figurer
explicitement que le projet de loi de
finances un montant significatif
déterminant pour le lancement de cet
opus de cette métropole chacun
conviendra en effet que la dotation dit
exceptionnel de 50 millions n'est pas à
la hauteur de vos ambitions
métropolitaine pour un territoire de 92
communes et d'un miller 8 d'habitants
vous voulez que nous soyons au rendez
vous nous y serons
mais pour que nous puissions écrire
l'histoire il faut nous en donner le
moyen monsieur le premier ministre si
monsieur tessier
la parole est à madame la ministre la
décentralisation et la fonction publique
mal à marylise lebranchu
oui merci merci le président mesdames et
messieurs le député monsieur le député
guy teissier effectivement sur la
métropole aix marseille provence un
certain nombre d'engagements ont été
pris par le prédécesseur de manuel valls
jean marc ayrault est votre geste ne
rejoint pas l'arrêt
été parce que il ya effectivement de
niveau vous avez le niveau de la baisse
des dotations aux collectes et
territoriales toutes les communes de
france sont touchées plus ou moins en
fonction de leur situation et le premier
ministre manuel valls a pris
l'engagement de 1 milliard des aides à
l'investissement je clos ce premier
chapitre même si on pourrait en discuter
longtemps le second c'est la justesse de
la répartition aix marseille provence et
en particulier parce que vous avez un
certain nombre de quartiers de politique
de la ville mais aussi de grandes zones
en difficulté bénéficiera d'une
péréquation
vous le savez monsieur guy teissier
parce que vous avez sans doute fait les
projections je compte sur vous dans le
poste qui est le vôtre aujourd'hui au
niveau de marseille métropole déjà que
vous avez déjà fait votre projections
pour l'année prochaine les choses vont
plutôt bien et enfin nous avons pris cet
engagement de regarder de près pourquoi
marseille en particulier à l'intérieur
de sa métropole avait une déçue
extrêmement faible par rapport aux
autres grandes métropoles ou quartier
équivalent en france et nous proposons à
l'assemblée nationale au moment du
projet de loi de finances maintenant
dans quelques jours de revoir les règles
pour que justement la dsu ne fais pas
subir un certain dont marcel se rend
mauvais qui fait que la dotation est
trop basse donc vous aurez une bonne
surprise
vous aurez meilleure dotation des six
déçus une meilleure dotation de
péréquation et enfin nous nous sommes
engagés et nous tiendrons parole
est-ce que les dotations d'aix marseille
provence et de paris ne pénètre de
pénalise pas pardon l'ensemble des
enveloppes de dgf monsieur taissy merci
madame la ministre la séance des
questions au gouvernement et terminer la
séance est suspendue pour cinq minutes